Podcast-Ufo-Intro mit diesem Rhythmus.
Stundenlang. Das Opfer-Udo. So viel kann gar nicht Lustiges gesprochen werden. Nee. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge 171. 171-Gagbande mit Stefan Tietze. Die Bombenentschärfungsnummer. Und wirklich jetzt? Hör auf mit deinem Scheiß. Du hast auch letztes Mal das schon mit diesem Kartensperr falsch gesagt. Jetzt will ich nicht wissen, wie viele Leute extra ihre Karten weggeschmissen haben in die Fußgängerzone, um mal diese Kartensperrnummer ausprobieren zu können. Du hast sie falsch gesagt. Doch, ich hab wieder alle Nachrichten bekommen wahrscheinlich, weil die Leute das wieder verwechseln. Ich hab bestimmt 80 Nachrichten bekommen, dass die Nummer falsch ist. Ich habe viele Schwächen, es gibt viele Dinge, die ich nicht weiß, aber wenn ich eines weiß, dann sind es Hotlines und Anrufstellen, wo man in Notfall anrufen muss, weil tatsächlich früher in meinem Elternhaus über dem Telefon hing immer so ein großes Karree mit ganz vielen Nummern drauf und da stand dann, was machen bei Gift, was machen bei Eichhörnchen und Bombenentschärfung ist 171, 171. Also falls ihr in eurem Garten irgendwie beim, jetzt ist ja Frühling, jetzt gräbt man mal um, schön die Radieschen anlegen, wenn ihr da irgendwie so eine schöne Fliegerbrandbombe findet, dann einfach kurz durchklingeln, 171, 171, ganz kurze Wartezeit und dann kommen die auch vorbei. Kurze Wartezeit? Dauert nur 10 Minuten, 10 bis 15 Minuten. Ja, das ist so ein Ding, also angenommen, du hast jetzt so ein Büro und du bist halt Bomben entschärfer. Aber was geil wäre, Leidenschaft. Was total geil wäre, aber wenn die so eine Wartemelodie hätten und die einfach so ein Takt ticken ist. Ah ja, Sex, Bom, Sex, Bom. Ach so, ich dachte so ein Countdown. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da Scherze machen kann.
Ich glaube, die nehmen das sehr, sehr ernst.
Und das Problem ist halt, wie viele Leute setzt du da ans Telefon,
halt bei der Bombenhotline.
Du denkst dir ja, na ja, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass zwei Leute gleichzeitig eine Bombe in ihrem Karten finden,
und dann hast du halt da eine Person an der Hotline.
Aber eine sehr kompetente Person wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die kennt sich dann sehr, sehr gut aus.
Ja, kann man auch wegen Kalorienbomben anrufen? Wow! Das hab ich vermisst über Skype. Einfach dieses knallhart Reinschreien und offensichtliche Verzerren der eigenen Stimme. Das hab ich vermisst. Ja, es ist eine Skype-Folge. Ihr habt schon am Delay gemerkt, daran, dass wir jetzt immer reinreden. Das Lachen zehn Minuten zu spät kommt, ihr habt's gecheckt, ihr wisst Bescheid, das ist eine richtige Skype-Folge, Skype hat sich trotz Update wieder nicht verbessert. Es gibt ja oft so Momente, wo man mal mit einer Person für einen Anlass skypt, irgendwie dann, keine Ahnung, für ein Projekt dann oder irgendjemand, wo man mal sagt, ja, lass uns mal skypen, und dann hat man die den Rest seines Lebens immer im Kontaktbuch. Und immer wenn man dann Skype aufmacht, um dann irgendwie mit dem guten alten Stefan T. zu reden, dann hat man diese ganzen Kontaktleichen und dann sind die online und dann fühle ich mich immer so beobachtet. Der sieht jetzt, dass ich online bin. Der so, ja, ich habe die mal vor sieben Jahren für die Schülerzeitung geskypt und jetzt sieht er, dass ich online bin. Und ich traue mich aber auch nicht, den Kontakt abzubrechen, weil irgendwie finde ich es unhöflich. Man weiß aber nicht, kriegt der andere, das ist auch im Internet so eine Sache, weil alle Social-Media-Dienste handhaben das ja anders. Also wenn du jetzt jemanden, wenn du etwas löscht, sehen, in manchen Diensten sieht man, dass man den Freund entfernt hat. Das ist halt bei jedem unterschiedlich. Bei Skype kannst du, glaube ich, einfach löschen, ohne dass der andere sieht, dass du ihn gelöscht hast. Aber ich habe das auch gerade gehabt. Ich war lange, habe ich bei Skype auf dich gewartet und habe dann mal links rumscrollt, was das für Kontakte waren. Und wir haben das ja häufig, dass wir mal interviewt werden oder für Bachelorarbeiten oder sowas kurz mal Interview führen müssen. Und links waren so ganz viele Kontakte von Leuten, die ich noch nie gehört habe. Und ich habe es völlig akzeptiert, aber dann nach zehn Minuten ist mir aufgefallen, das war gar nicht mein Skype-Account. Ich war in einem falschen Skype-Account eingelangt. Aus Versehen reingehackt. Aus Versehen, Passwort richtig geraten, ja. Nee, aber das hätte ich auch völlig gekauft. Zum Beispiel unsere Lieblingsastronomin und Physikerin Anna Frebel, die habe ich auch noch im Skype-Kontakt. Und manchmal ist die halt online. Aber die hat es auch schon mal angerufen. Hast du den Bildschirm so gedreht, nach oben hast du gesagt, ist das der große Wagen? Da! Der Himmel blinkt! Sehen Sie? Was ist das, kennen Sie diesen Stern schon? Können wir den nach mir benennen? Ist UFO oder ISS? Das ist der Mond. Ach so. Aber das ist der große Wagen da, oder? Man sieht nur schwarz. Man sieht nur schwarz. Da! Sehen Sie nicht! Orion! Der Gürtel des Orion. Das ist der einzige, den man immer erkennt tatsächlich ganz gut. Und vom Gürtel des Orion ist auch der, ja, jetzt nage ich mich nicht darauf fest, der Nordstern oder Polarstern. Ist der Nordstern oder Polarstern, weiß ich nicht, aber so ein Stern ist da ein heller Stern in der Nähe auf jeden Fall. Vom Gürtel des Orion. Ich finde es aber schade, dass so diese ganzen modern entdeckten Sterne, dass die alle so technische Begriffe haben, die heißen dann immer so E, B, N, 1, 1, 5, 3. Früher, da haben die sich noch wirklich mal Gedanken gemacht, irgendwie, da hast du den Bären
und den Eich und den Krebs.
Und den Todesstern, da hast du alles so egal.
Ja, das war mal ein Kreativ.
So, und jetzt irgendwie alles nur Nummern. Kann man das nicht eigentlich ausschreiben?
Und dann heißt es dann irgendwie Schwarze Loch in der Nähe
irgendwie von Bimboletti
oder irgendwie vom kleinen Hamster.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Früher irgendwie mit Kepler und so,
da war Astronomie so ein Volksding, weil alle hatten keine Ahnung und jeder so, ja, Bär, oder? Ja, passt schon. Heute sind die Wissenschaftler zu weit abgehoben, so, die sind zu krass, man kann gar nicht mehr mitreden.
Stell dir mal vor, wir stossen irgendwann mal auf eine Alienrasse und die sagen, ah, hier, aus dem Sternbild kleiner Hamster und wie die ganze Erde sofort beleidigt wäre. Ganz kurz, ganz kurz, wo sind wir? Im kleinen Hamster. Ihr seid dieses Pummelschwänzchen, das Schwänzchen da hinten dran. Wir sind der Schwanz? Ihr hättet nie gedacht, dass wir im kleinen Hamster eine intelligente Lebensform finden. Ihr seid ja süss, das ist ja süss. Ihr Hamsterchen. Sieht sogar ein bisschen aus mit euren Wänkchen, oder? Werden die rot? Oh, komm, die werden ja ganz rot!
Amstdäckchen! Na, hallo!
Und dann, ich glaub, eine ganze Spezies wär,
eine hochintelligente Spezies,
von einem auf den anderen Momenten einfach total beleidigt.
Deswegen, glaub ich, hat man da irgendwann mit aufgehört.
Und jetzt nennt man die halt HXler, HX-93.
Ist okay.
Da kann man sich irgendwie darauf verständigen.
Das ist nicht so gut.
Also, das Intro war von Lars, haben wir schon gesagt? Nee. Doch, vielen Dank an Lars. Vielen Dank an Lars. Dieser, äh, letzte Woche über diesen Beat, diesen Raggetron Beat oder was auch immer. Und das ist so geil, dafür liebe ich auch die Podcast-Sufo-Community, dass ich sage, ich hasse diesen Beat und als Antwort kriege ich ganz viele so Nachrichten, ah, guck mal, hier wird erklärt, wie der Beat der Beat funktioniert ah schau mal, hier ist der Rhythmus, das ist er doch, oder? Und verlinken mir genau diesen Rhythmus, wo ich einfach denke, das ist Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Ich habe mir wirklich so ein Video angeschaut, wo wirklich 13 Minuten lang dieser fucking Rhythmus erklärt wird und er nervt mich immer noch. Wie sagt man das? Raggeton. Das ist nicht genau. Ist Raggy die Kurzform für Raggathon? Dafür liebe ich ja auch unsere Community, dass wir immer sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen. Also wir haben eine sehr, sehr aktive Community, aber bestimmt zehn verschiedene Namen haben bekommen. Wie damals, als wir wissen wollten, wie das Intro von Futurama abgeleitet wird, 20 verschiedene Songs. Und alle aber mit so einem Selbstbewusstsein,
dass man sagt, ja, ich gönne allen den Sieg.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat nur einer von euch wieder recht.
Aber ich habe auch ganz viele Nachrichten bekommen,
wie dieser Beat heißt.
Und es ist, glaube ich, Reggaeton.
Reggaeton.
Das ist eine Mischung aus Reggae, Hip-Hop und Merengue.
Ja, okay.
Das ist jedenfalls sehr interessant, und das haben uns viele geschickt. Und einer hat auch geschrieben, dass er gerade in Peru ist und langsam wahnsinnig wird wegen dieses Beats. Und man kann es nachvollziehen. Mir in Mexiko ging es auch nicht anders. Glaubst du, die freuen sich, wenn man den mal einen anderen Beat zeigt? Wenn man einfach mal sagt, knallhart, t, t, t, und alle freuen sich dann darüber sehr? Wir könnten deren Despacito schreiben.
Also ich glaube, so Missionare und so werden ja irgendwann so ein bisschen kritisch betrachtet, irgendwie war keine gute Idee, aber vielleicht war einfach auch die frohe Botschaft des Christentums die falsche Botschaft.
Vielleicht sollte man einfach reingehen, einfach mal so einen schönen, knackigen Viervierteltag, eins, zwei, drei, vier, Betonung auf eins und drei, einfach mal knallhart unter die Lande bringen.
Das ist ja auch einfach mal so. Ich glaube, das Problem ist, weil man sagt ja immer so lateinamerikanisch irgendwie, da gibt es dann so Strassenfeste und alle tanzen den ganzen Tag, einfach weil die einen zu einnehmenden Rhythmus haben, so, weißt du, wir Deutschen, wir haben halt dann irgendwie so Bahnstecken, da kannst du dann nicht irgendwie hüftenschwingend durch die Strassen wandeln, deswegen halten wir auch einfach mal die fucking Klappe und sitzen zu Hause und sind ruhig. Ja, das ist wie so ein Virus, das ist wie so ein Virus, der sich über Länder erstreckt und alle, die von Raggatron befallen sind, kriegen auch keine wirklich, mal ganz im Ernst, wirkliche Wirtschaft, die funktioniert mehr auf die Kette, die kriegen dann, die tanzen halt durch die Straßen. So, und dann kann man sich, wie ein Rio-Karneval, kann man sich schön angucken, so, die Wirtschaft ist trotzdem am Boden, einfach weil der Raggatron sich langsam ausstreckt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch gut, wenn er nach Deutschland schwappt, dann ist ja auch vorbei. Aber ist das der späte Sieg der Sowjetunion, die gesagt haben, irgendwie klappt das nicht, lass uns mal Gegner bekämpfen, lass uns mal so Samba-Tänzer, russische Samba-Tänzer infiltrieren, die diesen Drecksrhythmus einfach in alle Länder bringen. Und viele Wirtschaften leiden heute noch drunter. Sehr tragisch tatsächlich. Ja, das ist so der wahre Kalte Krieg. Man merkt gar nicht, dass Krieg ist, aber die haben langsam diesen Beat in den Ländern verteilt. Ist nicht auch Despacito das erfolgreichste YouTube-Video aller Zeiten? Ist ja auch ständig dieses ... Ich komme ja jetzt gerade vom EMS-Training, da lief Despacito die ganze Zeit. Ich glaube glaube bestimmt achtmal, während ich da war. Und ich muss sagen, das ist die best, die frisch geduschteste Folge aller Zeiten wahrscheinlich. Ich war noch nie so frisch geduscht. Haar aus der Dusche, nein, Haare sind noch nass, komplett nass. Haare, nass und frisch geduscht direkt vor das Mikro gesetzt. Ich glaube, so gut waren wir noch nie geduscht. Schüttelst du deine Haare, um die zu trocknen? Föhnen, ja. Nee, schütteln. Nee, schütteln habe ich noch nicht für mich gedacht. Bringt das was bei dir, aber du hast auch so eine Mähne. Naja, schon. Also ich denke mir so, also zum Beispiel dieses klassische T-Shirt aus Wringen. Wringen, auch ein herrliches Wort. Ein tolles Wort, wirklich. Hat Hölderlin mal was zu Wringen geschrieben? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Wunderschön. Und dann ist es auch so, dann hängst du so dein T-Shirt auf und dann tropft es ewig runter und dann denkst du, das heißt die ganze Nacht getrocknet, du kannst es aber noch auswringen. Eigentlich falsche Reihenfolge, eigentlich musst du es erst auswringen. Also erst müssen die groben Geräte ran und dann können die feinen Geräte ran, dann irgendwie mit Diffusion oder so geht dann über die Nacht die Feuchtigkeit raus. Und so, denke ich mir, ist es bei Hahn auch. Und das Hand Handtuch ist fast noch ein zu feines Instrument. Erst mal den Hund machen, erst mal schütteln, das Gröbste rauskriegen. Das ganze Badezimmer nass machen, das ist die oberste Regel. Auch den Spiegel versauen, erst mal direkt. Naja, es ist ja nicht das ganze, du schüttelst dich sozusagen seitlich, als würde man den Kopf schütteln. Und dadurch hast du in deinem ganzen Badezimmer so einen rundherum gehenden Streifen Wasser, der dann auch schön anschimmelt. Also du hast dann genau auf Kopfhöhe, also auf Stirnhöhe hast du dann ein Schimmelring einmal direkt durchs Badezimmer. Das ist perfekt. Und wichtig ist auch, dass man erst Gedanken verloren guckt, sich plötzlich ganz ruckhaft geschüttelt und dann wieder in seinen alten Gedanken für sich verliert, wie das Hunde so machen. Wo man nicht weiß, wo dieser Schüttelimpuls plötzlich herkommt.
Menschen bereiten sich ja auch
Bewegungen vor. Und das Tolle an Tieren
ist auch einfach dieses impulsive
Ich habe jetzt den
Impuls, mich zu schütteln, schüttel mich auch jetzt
direkt und hab den dann auch
schnell nicht mehr. Aber bei Menschen
sieht man immer, da bahnt sich Bewegungen immer an.
Das finde ich ganz aus.
Ja, okay, nee, schütteln kommt bei mir nicht.
Bei mir kommt direkt das Handtuch, muss ich sagen.
Dann Luft trocknen, dann immer allerdings Salzspray.
Salz? Du salzt deine Haare?
Ich salze meine Haare.
Die Idee ist einfach, Salzwasser nachzumfinden aus dem Meer.
Und dann zu föhnen.
Dann muss ich quasi nichts bei meinen Haaren machen.
Die sind dann schon so, wie sie sein sollen.
Früher habe ich oft Gel benutzt oder direkt einfach Wachs, aber dann muss man halt so viel benutzen, dass sie dann verklebt aussehen. Das ist so ein Trick an Leute, die die Haare machen, gerne Salzspray benutzen, das macht die Haare schon grifffest. Beauty-Tipp. Ist das der Grund, warum Menschen, die am Meer leben, einfach schöner sind? Ja. Weil sie einfach immer perfekte Haare haben, weil sie im Saal so Hawaii, wenn man jetzt so denkt, irgendwie Aquaman oder die Surfer, Surfer Boys, California Boys, die haben immer perfekte Haare, wahrscheinlich einfach wegen des Salzwassers, oder? Es ist, glaube ich, eine Mischung aus Tan, Sonnen-Tan, Sport, auch nicht zu unterschätzen, und Salzwasser, ja. Ich glaube, das ist die perfekte Mischung. Und diese Ketten, diese Haifischketten. Es ist schon merkwürdig, dass das Schönheitsideal unserer Kultur exakt dem Strandgänger entspricht. Also es könnte ja auch dem Bergsteiger oder dem Tundraläufer entsprechen, so ein dicker Mantel und so eine, wo dann die Nase so eingefroren ist und die Haarspitzen sind weiss, weil sie gefroren sind. Das könnte auch Schönheitsideal sein. Nee, wir haben uns dazu entschieden, Schönheits sind die Leute, die am Strand sind. Ja, interessant, ne? Aber alle können sich darauf einigen. Schönheitsideal ist California Surferboy. Ja, bestimmt schon. Genau, aber früher war es ja anders. Früher war es ja der dicke König. Und ich würde mal gerne wissen, das hat ja noch Sinn ergeben auf eine Art, aber du willst doch nicht mit einem California Surferboy abhängen. Der ist doch nur, erstmal, der hat ganz andere Themen als wir zum Beispiel. Also wir würden mit einem California Surferboy, würden wir nicht so gut klarkommen, glaube ich. Seid ihr ein California Surferboy, dann meldet euch, wir würden dich oder euch gerne kennenlernen oder ein Surfergirl und dann können wir mal gucken, dann können wir mal schauen, ob wir ein Gespräch zusammenbekommen oder ob man über dieses Schütteln der rechten Hand mit ausgestreckten Kleinen und Daumenfinger hinauskommt, wer weiß. Ich glaube, darüber kommt es nicht hinaus. Aber das ist doch blöd, dass das unser Schönheitsideal ist, weil früher hat das ja Sinn gemacht. Du wolltest jemandem, der deinem Kind, als Frau jetzt deinem Kind Sicherheit bietet, in Form von finanzieller Sicherheit und Essen und sowas. Und deswegen fandst du Könige attraktiv. So, aber heutzutage finden wir California Surfer Girls, Surfer Boys attraktiv. Was genau glauben wir denn, was die uns bringen? Die können halt auf Wellen reiten, bei richtigem Wellengang, der zweimal im Jahr ist und können ihre Haare cool schütteln. Ja, aber vielleicht gehört die Menschheit auch einfach an den Strand. Vielleicht ist es der evolutionäre Tritt, wo uns die Natur sagt, Leute, ihr seid in der fucking Tundra, hier ist Eis. Wie wär's denn mal mit einem Strand? Ich glaube auch, dass der Mensch am besten aussieht in Sonnenlicht, in strahlendem Sonnenlicht. Und das ist eigentlich nur ein Zeichen, dass die Natur uns sagen will, Leute, geht in die Sonne, geht an den Strand, geht irgendwo hin, wo es verrückte Idee, aber vielleicht nicht kalt ist, sondern eher warm, geht vielleicht dahin. Und der Mensch so, nö, ich baue mir hier aus Schnee ein Haus. Ich bleibe hier im Schnee.
Wo ich einen Bären töten muss, um mir ein Fell
daraus zu machen. Und dabei sterben
80 Prozent meines Volkes.
Du baust hier aus Schnee
ein Haus? Naja, Eis.
Naja, weisst du, ich habe riesige
Sägen und dann säge ich mir so grosse Würfel
raus. Das ist unfassbar aufwendig.
Pass mal auf, schau mal, hier, was ist das? Das ist eine Schneeschaufel. Ich bin blind, weil sie so kalt ist. Sorry, tot, ich bin tot. Es gibt ... Gut, dann ... Gut, also, du bist der Sohn, dein Vater ist gerade erfroren. Ja. Hast du Lust auf Surfen? Ja, ja, nein. Gut, nein? Nee, ich will doch lieber, nein, ich will lieber
hierbleiben. Doch im Schnee.
Doch im Schnee bleiben. Ich hab 50 Wörter
für Schnee, ich hab keines für Sand.
Sand, wie wär's damit?
Haben Surfer auch 50 Wörter
für Sand?
Den hau ich jetzt raus. Weißt du was?
Mal wieder eine alte
Twitter-Folge. Weißt du, früher bei Skype
haben wir mal getwittert. Ich hau jetzt den Gag raus, haben Surfer 50 Wörter für Sand. Einfach mal so. Wir haben ja eigentlich den Podcast nur angefangen, um neue Tweets zu generieren. Ja. Und andersrum, wir haben den Podcast gestartet, um unsere Tweets darin vorzulesen. Also diese Verkoppelung ist schon lange getrennt worden, aber sie war immer da. Ich, einfach mal so,
heute ist weder Tag des Surfers noch Eurovision-Surfer-Contest,
ich hau einfach mal
einen Tweet raus. Haben Surfer eigentlich
auch 50 Wörter für Sand? Sand in Anführungszeichen
dann aber schon, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
In Anführungszeichen.
Dieser eine Strich, den man macht, wenn der ganze
Satz schon in Anführungszeichen ist.
Wenn du, ich weiß, wenn du über ein Wort redest, machst du keine Anführungszeichen. Wenn du sagst, mein Lieblingswort ist Eimer, setzt du Eimer auch nicht in Anführungszeichen, weil es gibt dafür keinen Grund. Und 50 würdest du ausschreiben, okay, habe ich, und ausschreiben, die 50 oder einfach als Zahl, als Zahl, ne? Nee, nee, fünf null, gute, fünf zu jungen. Haben Surfer eigentlich auch 50 Wörter für Sand? Ja, oder eher. Nee, eher nicht, oder? Eher Wasser oder Wellen. Nee, Sand ist schon, ja, habe ich mir auch überlegt, Wellen, aber eigentlich ist Sand besser, weil Sand ist näher an Schnee. Ja, ja, ich höre mal raus und weil die, weil unser Problem ist, dass wir lange Zeit nicht mehr getwittert haben und dann halt in so eine, dann bildet sich halt so eine Erwartungshaltung. Weil entweder, ich weiß auch nicht warum, weil entweder denken
die Leute, dass wir jetzt ewig an einem Tweet sitzen,
am nächsten erfolgreichen
Riesentweet, oder einfach,
weil es ist jetzt, du kannst nicht mit einem
schlechten Tweet anfangen wieder. Deswegen habe ich jetzt
beim Eurovision Song Contest mal wieder ein bisschen getwittert,
einfach um mal wieder so die Rohre
freizubekommen.
Der wird bestimmt auch so in den Kommentar kommen, oh, dafür haben wir
jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre gewartet. Ja, genau. Aber das ist doch falsch. Die sollen noch froh sein, dass überhaupt mal wieder was kommt. Ja, aber ich finde die These sehr interessant, dass die Natur uns langsam zum Strandböder bekommen will, weil wir kommen ja aus dem Wasser. Eben, wir sind ja an den Strand gekrochen. Genau, und jetzt kriege ich ... Sollen wir wieder ins Wasser?
Wir tun uns ja immer entscheiden, aber ich hab das Gefühl, weil die Natur ...
Ich hab früher immer wahnsinnig Heuschnupfen gehabt,
da wo ich herkam, auf vom Land.
Und dann war ich im Sommer immer drei Wochen an der Ostsee,
in Scharbeutz jedes Jahr.
Und da war immer schön mehr Luft, keine Ahnung, woran es lag.
Auf jeden Fall hatte ich da ...
Vielleicht auch, weil nicht so viele Pollen am Strand sind,
aber da hatte ich gar keine Probleme mit Heuschnupfen. Und da habe ich auch so gedacht, ja die Natur will mich hier haben. Ich muss zum Strand, ich muss wieder ins Wasser. Vielleicht ist es so ein Pendel-Effekt. Die Wassertiere werden an den Strand gezogen, um rauszukommen und wir müssen jetzt wieder so zurück pendeln. Und dann dürfen wir es halt nicht übertreiben und ins Wasser laufen, sondern wir müssen halt irgendwie am Strand stehen bleiben. Ja, kann gut sein. Ich weiß nicht. Tweet kommt miserabel an. Leute hassen den Tweet. Hast du eigentlich 50 Wörter für grosse Bilder ohne Rahmen? Puh. Einfach nur Puh ausgeschrieben. Wie Puh ausgeschrieben? Wie würdest du Puh abkürzen?
P-U, P-U-Punkt. Wofür steht eigentlich Puh? Puhlika? Ja, kann sein. Oder ist es einfach die Verschriftlichung des Ausdrucks, dieses wenn die backen, dieses, weißt du? Ach so, Puh. Dieses erschöpfte Puh. Ja, stimmt schon, ne? Ja. Aber du hast recht, Wringen ist ganz toll. Diese Idee, ein W mit einem R zu kombinieren, kommt ja auch sonst nicht mehr vor. Das ist das englische Wrangler. To wrangle. Ich habe auch gerade... Dieses Grunzen, was da drin schon ist. Zurück zur Natur, zurück zum Wolf. Aber es ist schon komisch, wenn wir jetzt dieses Puh haben,
da ist es ja so onomatopoetisch,
also das Wort klingt so ähnlich wie das, was es beschreibt, aber bei Wringen,
Wring,
was ist das?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich bin mir auch nicht genau sicher.
Du,
ich habe mir jetzt ein Fahrrad, wollte ich mir jetzt zulegen,
weil ich hätte gerne ein schönes Rennrad und bin dann in diesen Laden gegangen und habe gesagt, ich hätte gerne ein Rennrad mit Gangschaltung und dann hat der Typ direkt gesagt, Rennräder haben nur Gangschaltung und hat dann die Augen verdreht und gesagt, was glaubst du sonst, was die haben und dann habe ich auch gedacht, ja, also ich habe mich jetzt schon enttarnt als jemand, der keine Ahnung hat. Wahrscheinlich kosten jetzt alle Räder auch direkt mehr Geld. Wahrscheinlich, ja. Und ich bin dann nur quasi aus Höflichkeit noch eine, habe ich einen Fahrradtest gefahren. Aber es ist wirklich interessant, weil ich habe gedacht, ich kann einfach jetzt hier auch rausgehen. Man muss nämlich, das ist nämlich auch wichtig, glaube ich, beim Kaufen, gerade von so gebrauchten Sachen, du musst immer, ich glaube, der Preis entscheidet sich vor allem durch dein Auftreten. Niemand verarscht dich, wenn du souverän wirkst. Ich glaube aber, dass es tatsächlich auch eine Verkaufsstrategie sein kann. Ich glaube, wenn du merkst, da kommt jemand rein, der hat keinen Plan, ist, glaube ich, so eine Einschüchterung eine gute Verkaufsstrategie, weil wenn der sagt, ja, alle Fahrräder haben Gangschaltungen, dann will ich dieses Negativ des sozialen Status wieder ausgleichen und will dann dem möglichst dann viel kaufen oder mich möglichst irgendwie interessiert geben oder dann möglichst sagen, ja, ich nehme dann die Pumpe auch noch. Ich glaube, das könnte auch eine Strategie sein, das ist so ein bisschen diese Pick-up-Artist-Nagging-Strategie auf Verkaufsebene, dass du den Kunden fertig machst, so dass der Kunde dir gefallen möchte oder eingeschüchtert ist und aufhört zu denken und einfach in so einer animalischen Panikphase ist und ich muss hier einfach nur noch durchkommen. Ja, ich nehme das Rad. Okay, ja, ja, ich kaufe das noch, ja, ich kaufe das noch. Ich will einfach nur raus. Und ich glaube, also bei mir funktioniert das sehr, sehr gut.
Ich gebe mehr Geld aus, wenn ich Angst habe.
Oder ist es auch so ein, jetzt muss ich ihn auf anderer Ebene beeindrucken,
ja, ich nehme das Rad für 1000 Euro.
Oder ist es so was, so ein Ur-Mensch-Instinkt, dass man jetzt sagt,
nee, aber ich kann dafür sehr viel Geld jetzt bezahlen.
Oder ich weiß auch nicht, woran das dann liegt.
Aber das stimmt schon, das hatte ich dann auch tatsächlich so ein bisschen, wenn man sich recht überlegt, will man dann doch auch gefallen. Und wie viele Fahrräder hast du gekauft? 15, dann nur. Stefan. 15 viel zu grosse Fahrräder. Ich bin jetzt kein Fahrrad-Experte, aber brauche ich wirklich drei Helme? Na, mindestens, also mindestens drei. Naja, für den Winter, für den Sommer und dann halt, wenn sie schneller fahren. Schneller fahren als 15 kmh, brauchen sie einen Twizzahlhelm. Letztens unterwegs gewesen, Hamburg und ein Bild gesehen, das ich noch nicht so nicht gesehen habe. Und zwar, ich sag wie es ist, Erwachsener auf einem Einrad. Ah, normal in der Strasse unterwegs und da dachte ich mir, hm, klar man denkt irgendwie so Hipster, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, aber ich habe ja lange mit Kindern gearbeitet in meinem Zivildienst, jedes Mädchen ist da ein Rad gefahren und eigentlich interessant, dass wahrscheinlich von denen heute niemand mehr ein Rad fährt. Also es ist eine Sportart, ein Fortbewegungsmittel, was ausschliesslich von Kindern und da hauptsächlich Mädchen verwendet wird, aber darüber hinaus gar nicht.
Obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht so doof ist, weil es ist ja sehr klein. Du kannst es irgendwie mit in die U-Bahn nehmen, mit in den Bus nehmen. Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch niemanden auf dem Souverän auf dem Einradfahren sehen. Oder vielleicht ist Souveränes oder ist es Leute, die gut fahren, ist bei denen auch dieser kontinuierliche Struggle. Dieses Arme links und rechts zur Seite und panisch wedeln, um die Balance zu halten. Ist das, fährt man so professionell ein Rad oder habe ich einfach noch niemanden gesehen, der das richtig macht? Es ist halt immer so, 40 Prozent, ich will vorankommen, 60 Prozent, ich will nicht umfallen. Ja, genau. Also das ist immer so ein bisschen dieses Antrieb. Und das große Problem, und oft geht es ja auch so bei Fortbildungsmitteln, gerade Fortbildungsmittel haben ja oft einen starken Ausdruckswert. Ich will ein cooles Fahrrad, ein BMX, ich will ein cooles Auto, ich will coole Schuhe. Alles, was mit Transport zu tun hat, hat einen hohen Statuseffekt aus irgendeinem Grund, vielleicht früher Pferde oder sowas. Und das große Problem bei Fortbildungsmitteln ist immer, wohin mit den Armen? Ja, wohin mit den Armen? Das grosse Problem am Einrad ist, die Arme, entweder sie flattern panisch in der Luft herum, was uncool ist, oder sie hängen einfach Schlapp herunter, was genauso uncool ist. Das ist der Riesenvorteil vom Fahrrad. Vom Segway, ach so, andere Gedanken, andere Gedanken. Man bräuchte eigentlich ein Einrad mit so Armlehnen links und rechts dran, dass man so cool seine Arme schön armlehnen wie so ein Sessel,
also dass man nicht uncool aussieht, aber trotzdem noch so, wenn es nötig ist, irgendwie so ein bisschen rudern kann mit den Armen, aber einfach einen souveränen Eindruck macht. Es gibt diese schöne Szene in der Serie von Louis C.K., wo es darum geht, dass der Rücken wehtut und der Arzt einfach sagt, ja, die Menschen sind auch nicht dazu gemacht, zu gehen, sondern eigentlich immer noch, um auf allen Vieren zu laufen. Das war halt damals so und dann hat sich der Mensch halt sehr schnell nach oben entwickelt. Aber eigentlich tut der Rücken halt weh, weil wir tendenziell immer noch dafür für die Waagerechte gemacht sind. Und das ist auch interessant, weil der Körper
hat sich irgendwann entschlossen, auf zwei Beinen zu gehen,
aber so ganz entschieden,
was man mit den Armen macht,
hat der Körper sich auch noch nicht.
Also wenn ich darauf achte,
in der Fußgängerzone, auf Menschen, was sie mit ihren Armen
machen während des Gehens,
und man sich da wirklich darauf fokussiert,
ist es das Lustigste, was man überhaupt machen kann,
an so einem schönen Samstag, wo die Sonne scheint, wo man nicht weiß, was man machen soll. Einfach in die Fußgängerzone stellen und gucken, was die Leute machen mit den Armen. Weil der Körper hat sich für, ja, wir lassen sie es erstmal, es ist wirklich wie so ein Provisorium, wie so eine provisorische Lösung, erstmal runterhängen lassen. Ja, ich glaube, es ist sowieso eine Theorie, dass jede kulturelle Erlangenschaft von Menschen einfach nur deswegen entstanden ist, weil die Menschen irgendwas verzweifelt versucht haben, mit den Händen zu tun. Werkzeug ist nur dadurch gefunden, dass sie halt awkward so einen Stock in die Hand genommen haben und dann halt so, oh krass, damit kann man einen Bienenstock nerven oder irgendwie dann Instrumente so. All das ist nur entstanden, weil der Mensch immer irgendwas sucht, um mit seinen Armen zu machen, um die nicht einfach so runterhängen zu lassen. Kein anderes Tier hat das. Ja, zu reflektiert ist, um Awkwardness zu ertragen. Wie Kühe auf der Weide können die ganze Zeit sich anschweigen. Sie sehen immer cool aus. Die haben 24-7 Awkward Silence. Die stehen nebeneinander, reden gar nicht. Menschen könnten das ja gar nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass Sprache entstanden ist aus so einer unangenehmen Stille. Ja, weil man die Aufmerksamkeit von seinen Awkward Armen ablenken wollte. Und dann sagt man halt so, wo kommst du her? Ja, vielleicht doch. Ich komme aus genau dem gleichen Dorf wie du, wir sind die drei einzigen Menschen momentan, Adam, Eva und Karl. Was soll man auch reden, wenn man die ganze Zeit das Gleiche erlebt? Es ist schwierig. Ich glaube, deswegen hat man sich dann auch so Götter ausgedacht und dann gesagt, ja, die wollen jetzt bestimmt, dass wir irgendwie Tiere fangen oder so. Ja, aber stell dir mal so eine Spinne oder sowas vor, die so vier coole Beine hat und zwei hängen einfach so runter einfach, die machen gar nichts. Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen, weil irgendwie alle Tiere, da haben alle Gliedmasse irgendwie einen Sinn, ausser bei Menschen, die, die dengeln da einfach runter.
Ja, ja, genau, weil die Schultern, die hängen einfach da dran, so wie angepappt. Aber wie ist es denn beim T-Rex zum Beispiel? Der hat ja ganz kleine Ärmchen. Haben die sich von grosseren Armen klein entwickelt oder von kleinen ganz kleinen dann doch noch? Wo man gesagt hat, okay, das ist definitiv zu klein, lasst es uns zumindest ein bisschen grösser machen. Jetzt wird es lächerlich. Jetzt wird es lächerlich. Nur ist es lustig. Aber hatte der irgendwann mal grössere und dann hat irgendjemand gesagt, Freunde, jetzt mal wirklich mal ganz ernst, wir brauchen das nicht, das brauchen wir nicht. Und dann 100 Generationen später hatten wir dann ganz kleine Arme. Es gibt ja auch diesen einen Dino, der die ganze Zeit Thumbs up zeigt. Ich glaube, der heißt Iguanodon, der die ganze Zeit so zwei riesen Daumen hat und diese Seite nicht hält. Der die ganze Zeit Okidoki-Saurus, warte mal, Iguanodon, ich glaube, das ist der, aber hör mal auch mit Dinosauriern, ich habe nämlich furchtbare Sachen erfahren, nämlich, der T-Rex hatte, also der junge T-Rex hatte ein komplettes Federkleid, ganz junger T-Rex. Gut, du musst jetzt nicht Federkleid sagen, du kannst auch sagen, er hat Federn, du machst es nicht besser. Federdress. Wirklich komplett ein wunderschönes Federtütüchen. Federtütüchen. Und dann der ältere T-Rex hatte dann noch so ein, wie so eine. Der hatte Fell, so geflecktes Fell. Mit so Herzchen drauf, so Herzchenlister. Nee, der hatte dann tatsächlich oben so eine... Glitzer. Ja, so ein Glister-Dress an. Nee, nee, ein Abendkleid. Der hatte oben so ein Federkleid, was oben am Kopf so stehen geblieben ist. Also wie so ein gerupftes Hühnchen. Wie so ein Indianer, aber diese, weißt du, jetzt nicht die Vorsitzenden Indianer, nicht der Häuptling, sondern die da drunter, die mit so zwei Federn.. Der Sekretär. Ja, ja, genau. Ja, hier der Oguanodon. Ja, gut, der zeigt auch, der macht den Surfergruss. Der macht den Surfergruss die ganze Zeit. Wie cool ist das denn? Jetzt kommt alles zusammen. Die haben es auch schon gesehen, die Dinosaurier, dass die alle an den Strand müssen. Ich schicke dir das jetzt, das Bild. Aber ich kann mir nur so gut vorstellen, diese Paläontologen-Konferenz, wo irgendwie die krasseste führende Wissenschaftlerin hat alle Sachen nochmal zusammengefügt und gesagt, okay, revolutionär, so sah der T-Rex aus und der gesamte Saal, hunderttausend Wissenschaftler, alle so schauen so an die Wand und schauen auf den Boden und gucken sich so an. Buh! Scheiße. Ich glaube,, die wissen das auch schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Haben sie so geheim gehalten. Das wird unterdrückt.
Oh Gott, das ist so
peinlich, sahen die aus. Und
ein so ein Vogel,
da hieß es auch, die haben so ein Dinosaurier
jetzt in China gefunden. Lustigerweise,
Fun Fact, bis
zu dem Film, Jurassic Park,
wurden, in der ganzen Zeit
bis zu dem Film, wurden weniger Dinosaurier entdeckt, als nach dem Film bis heute. Und er kam 1999 raus, glaube ich. Oh, krass. Abgefahren, ne? Und weil man echt in China zu buddeln und da hat man so Riesendinosaurier gefunden, gegen die ist der tierisch ein Scheiß. Und die hatten teilweise komplett Federn. Komplett Federn. Manche hatten sogar Flügel, sind mit denen so durch die Gegend gelaufen, konnten aber nicht abheben, wie so Riesenvogelstraussen und hatten auch dieses große Gebiss, die waren viel gefährlicher, aber hatten Schnabel. Ja, der T-Rex hätte die besiegt. Das ist einfach peinlich, ey. So einfach. Vor allem, ich glaube, dass Jurassic Park, man sagt ja immer, danach haben ganz viele, wie du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, irgendwie Forscher, total aktiv geworden.
Aber ich glaube ja, der Film hat fast, danach haben ganz viele, wie du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, irgendwie Forscher, total aktiv geworden.
Aber ich glaube ja, der Film hat fast der Wissenschaft geschadet, weil dadurch Dinosaurier einfach so cool wurden, so emotional aufgeladen. Wohingegen bei so einer scheiß Krabbe oder so sagst du, ja mein Gott, die hat jetzt die blaue Fleck mit der grüne. Ja, da siegt die Wissenschaft, da siegen die Fakten. Richtig, ja, aber bei Dinosauriern, da hast du immer dieses und die die Wissenschaftler haben halt diese Actionfiguren und stoßen die so aneinander und so ungefähr stellen wir uns das vor.
Nein, nein, bring mich nicht um!
Und dann gehen wir davon aus, dass deswegen die meisten Dinosaurier ausgestorben sind.
Und dann, wenn du da einfach ankommst und sagst, oh, die hatten so ein schön feines, samtiges, schimmerndes Bläser. Bläser. Ja, so eine Toga an und so eine schöne Brosche, irgendwie so eine Federnbrosche. Und dann sagen die Alte, oh nee, und dann, ihr habt Ohrringe gefunden, das kann doch nicht euer fucking Ernst sein. Doch, so aus Knochen geformt, oh Gott. Oh, das ist unangenehm. Mit riesigen Ohrringe. Und manche hatten auch so ein Piercing. So ein Bauchnabel-Piercing. Ganz unangenehm. Ganz peinliches Schweigen auf der Paläthologen-Konferenz. Das darf niemals diesen Raum verlassen. Niemals. Naja, das finde ich blöd einfach. Blöd gelaufen. Aber weißt du, am Ende sieht die Wissenschaft und das ist einfach scheiße. Die hatten so Flügel und dann haben die die in die Weite gestreckt und dann konnten die damit balancieren. Worauf haben die denn balanciert? Warum muss die ... Oh Gott, diese Bilder sind einfach nur peinlich. Aber dieser Iguanodon ist wirklich albern. Der ist wirklich lächerlich. Der Iguanodon zeigt einfach, der hat zwei abgespreizte Finger, einen Daumen und den kleinen Finger. Das ist einfach nur peinlich. Man weiß nicht genau, was da an Tobas schiefgelaufen ist. Ja, aber wie gesagt, in China schaut man jetzt auch auf den Boden und guckt mal genau, was da so los ist. Da hat man sehr viele schöne Dinosaurier gefunden, aber alle Federn. Es ist gleichzeitig Surfergruss und ruf mich an. Und call me maybe. Ja, vielleicht wollen Surfer auch nur unbedingt mal angerufen werden. Ah, genau. Oviraptor ist nämlich der Krasse, der gefunden wurde, der irgendwie 80 Mal so groß ist wie der Tyrannosaurus Rex, aber einfach einen Schnabel hat, eine Riesenente quasi. Eine Riesenente mit so einem wahnsinnig schönen Federkleid. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie man sich so eine Alienrasse vorstellt, so ein bisschen wie so ein Geschöpft aus dem Film Avatar. Das ist alles Pein. Ovi Raptor, mit V. Ovi Raptor. Und das ist ein unfassbar riesiger Schneller-Dinosaurier. Und ich bin ein bisschen froh, dass man den vor Jurassic Park nicht entdeckt hat,
weil wenn das der böse Wicht gewesen wäre, der Main-Villain aus Jurassic Park,
wäre das, glaube ich, einfach ein peinlicher Slapstick-Film geworden.
Aber das sind ja Flügel mit Händen dran.
Ja, das ist einfach nur peinlich. Was ist das denn?
Und mit einem riesen Baseball-Handschuh, das ist einfach nur peinlich.
Sind das Absätze?
Ja, jetzt hinterfragt das nicht. Das sind Absätze und so ein Minirock. Das ist ja jetzt auch egal.
Aber ich bin jetzt auf der Seite von Schleich, von diesen Spielfiguren oder von diesen Spielfiguren.
Die machen aber auch Schotten zu, denen ist es komplett egal, was da an der wissenschaftlichen Front vor sich geht.
Ja, ich glaube, die werden sofort pleite gehen, weil die leben wahrscheinlich, machen wir 80% dieses Umsatzes mit Dinosauriern. Und wenn die da jetzt alle so Federnquatsch da haben, dann müssen die da so als Drachen verkaufen wahrscheinlich. Ja, das kann schon auch sein. Aber ich finde auch gut, dass man bei den Flugsauriern auch entschieden hat, ne, die haben keine Federn. Die sind, Das ist ja ... Warum bei denen eigentlich nicht? Das ist doch ... Damit könnte ich mich ja anfreunden zumindest. Naja. Wir sind schon wieder bei den Dinosauriern und den Federn. Es war eine Frage der Zeit. Folge 171, wir sind wieder da. 171, 171, die Bombenentschärfungshotline. Ruf durch, falls ihr Probleme habt. Nee, also ich war halt eben auf dem ehemaligen Schlachtfeld von der Schlacht von Verdun in Verdun unterwegs und habe da ein paar Granaten gefunden. Aber das ist auch nicht so überraschend. Also ich glaube, da würden die jetzt eher mich gähnend abwürgen, wenn ich da jetzt anrufen würde und sagen, ja, ich habe hier Granate gefunden. Aber hat Spaß gemacht, muss ich nochmal hin. Ist die 1711 auch so eine Nummer, wo man jetzt nicht auf Spaß anrufen kann? Nur mal einfach mal so, um zu gucken, um vielleicht ein paar Fragen zu beantworten zu lassen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, da darfst du nicht anrufen. Ja, nee, okay. Da kriegst du sogar Strafe, irgendwie so Störung von Hilfe oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Ja, aber
ist auch ein bisschen quatschig, oder?
Wie viele Bomben werden so am Tag gefunden?
Ja, du, ich glaube eine Menge,
oder? Also ich glaube die Hälfte der,
im Grossteil sind ja keine Bomben, dann findet man
irgendwie so einen grossen Tanzhapfen und dann hat man Angst.
Die heutigen Kinder wissen ja nicht mehr, wie die Bomben
aussehen. Haben ja keine Ahnung.
Ja, da ist schon halt kein gescheiten Krieg mehr hier.
Ja. Schönen Krieg. Du sagst, es ist einebe und dann kommt da jemand vorbei und sagt, er ist ein Igel. Ach so, ein Igel. Ja, gut, dann. Was soll das sein? Dann fahr ich wieder heim, oder was? Gut, setze ich mich wieder in mein Bombenmobil. Ach ja, und Igel haben Federn. Igel sind auch peinlich. Also die sind gar nicht so süss, glaube ich. Wenn man sich vom Nahen anguckt, kommen da viel tote Augen. Also ganz tote, dunkle Augen. Die haben ja gar keine Pupillen. Der Auge ist eine große Pupille. Ja, stimmt schon. Und jetzt der Sonic muss ja jetzt auch wieder neu gemacht werden, weil er zu hässlich ist. Da muss ich auch sehr drüber lachen. Diese ganze Sonic-Diskussion, die ja sehr auch emotional geführt wurde im Internet, aber, und ich als jemand, der mit Sonic gar nichts zu tun hat, fand es wahnsinnig lustig, wie er aber auch gerade dargestellt wurde in diesem Live-Action-Film, und es war ja so ein menschliches Gebiss, und es ist ja so eine wahnsinnig überzeichnete, sehr abstrakte Figur, also die hatte Null-Realitätsanspruch damals und ist ja super stilisiert. Und man hat trotzdem überlegt, nee, wir machen daraus einen Live-Action-Film und wir ziehen das aber auch durch. Es soll fotorealistisch aussehen, diese Figur. Und es kann ja auch nur schieflaufen. Ja, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob das irgendwie jetzt so ein Kulturwandel ist, weil das ist ja wirklich das allererste Mal, dass irgendwas geändert wird, einfach weil alle es scheiße finden. Ich meine, wir fanden, keine Ahnung, Star Wars Episode I, alle finden Jada Binks scheiße im Trailer und dann sagt man, ja, da machen wir die Augen noch mal ein bisschen grösser oder so. Also ich glaube, früher hat man das eher ein bisschen einfach so hingenommen. Natürlich fand man es irgendwie scheiße, aber dann jetzt Petitionen, das zu ändern und irgendwie so sollte es gut aussehen. Ja, wo kommt das eigentlich her, auch bei Game of Thrones? Ja, ansonsten irgendwie immer Body Positivity, Toleranz, wir akzeptieren alle, wie es sind. Aber dann halt irgendwie, Sonic hat zu lange Beine, der ist hässlich, der Scheiße ändert den. Daenerys hat was? Was hat die gemacht? Ja, ihr könnt auch nicht sehen, wie es ist einfach. Ja, diese Wut, genau, aber das stimmt schon auch, das ist auch nicht ganz konsequent.
Bei Unterhaltung hört der Spaß auf.
Ich glaube, wir haben einfach zu viel Interaktivität irgendwie, dass Leute das Gefühl haben, sie haben zu viel mit dem Kunstwerk zu tun.
Ich glaube, so in Shakespeare-Zeiten, also das würde Hamlet nie tun.
Wie, der bringt seinen Onkel nicht um, ne.
Das habe ich jetzt, eine Stunde lang habe ich mir jetzt den Charakter angeguckt undakter angeguckt. Können wir weitermachen? Wir würden gerne weiterspielen. Wir würden gerne einfach jetzt hier weiterspielen oben. Haben Sie noch ein Problem? Wir machen eine Petition, soll noch mal nachgeschrieben werden, hier von, wie heißt der hier, Goethe oder was, der soll das noch mal neu schreiben. Ich meine, Literaturwissenschaftler machen sich seit 500 Jahren Gedanken, warum Hamlet genau das macht und warum und das ist doch merkwürdig, aber vielleicht hat das hier einen Grund und dann wird interpretiert und analysiert und heute einfach, nee, scheiße, macht's anders. Petition. Das ändern wir jetzt. Petition wird anders gemacht. Das würde der nicht machen, scheiße. Aber mir gefällt das Petition. Einfach so, weil man halt, man kann, also Leute können ihre Wut rauslassen und glauben dann damit, was zu verändern, aber also niemand von den Game of Thrones Autoren hat jetzt wirklich Angst. Also, oh, da kommen sie mit ihrer Petition an. Natürlich ist es verletzend, aber die werden ja nichts ändern. Ich meine, du kennst dich ja da gut aus damit, die haben das ja wahrscheinlich schon vor einem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren oder so geschrieben und abgeschlossen. Das muss ja ewig gedreht werden. Also die sind ja wahrscheinlich schon im übernächsten Projekt jetzt wieder und dann irgendwie interessiert es natürlich auch. Ja gut, vielleicht ist es natürlich gekränkt, dass alle nicht so gut finden, viele nicht so gut finden die Staffel, aber naja. Aber ist ja auch bei dem Sonic-Ding auch so. Die haben ja auch schon alles fertig wahrscheinlich. Also wenn ein Trailer kommt, dann sind die ja schon super weit.
Ja, aber ist es da bei Computern nicht so Copy-Paste und dann ersetzt der ein Modell durch das andere? Ja, halt in jedem Frame nur. Es ist halt ein paar Mal Copy-Paste, ja. Aber das ist schon interessant, diese ganze Game of Thrones-Sache fand ich super spannend, aus so einer dramaturgischen Sicht natürlich, weil, und das wird man jetzt ja häufig mal haben in in der nächsten Zeit, und hatte man jetzt ja auch schon häufig, lustigerweise endet ja jetzt gerade alles, also Star Wars endet bald, die große Skywalker-Saga, Game of Thrones, so eine der grössten Serien unserer Zeit endet, dann diese ganze Avengers-Nummer hat jetzt geendet, also das gerade werden, gerade ist irgendwie so ein Bruch angesagt, und ich weiß gar, warum das alles so gerade aufeinander kommt, aber so die grössten Franchises hören gerade einfach auf mit und das ist natürlich auch alles dramaturgisch sehr spannend, weil sowas ist ja fast auch noch nie da gewesen, so grosse, also erstmal dieses Serienphänomen ist ja auch jetzt gerade so ein bisschen auf dem Höhepunkt. Und dieser Drang nach mehr Staffeln und mehr Staffeln und mehr Filmen und größeren Franchises und hier eine Intellectual Property und da. Aber gleichzeitig zu erwarten, dass man diese Reisen dann dramaturgisch gewohnt, wie man das halt gewohnt ist, zu Ende bringt, ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen blauäugig. Also ich meine, man kriegt ja auch mit, wie so so eine, wie so ein Game of Thrones dann entstanden ist und dass es der erste Roman Vorlage gab und man weiss ja auch, wie so ein George R. R. Martin dann auch schreibt und dann, dass er eher auch wie so ein Stephen King einfach mal losschreibt und sich gar nicht eine grosse Reise für alle Figuren überlegt hat und so und dann das Pech halte, dass es halt zum Riesen-Franchise wurde und jetzt alle ein super befriedigendes Ende erwarten. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob man dann da nicht andere Maßstäbe ansetzen muss und so. Keine Ahnung. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall dramaturgisch sehr spannend. Ich glaube, da passiert gerade sehr viel. Aber es ist schon schwer, eine Serie zu beenden. Ich glaube, du bist ja immer so dann im Aufbauen, Aufbauen, Aufbauen, Aufbauen und dann muss das alles innerhalb kürzester Zeit irgendwie da einreißen. Vielleicht muss man da irgendwie schon drei Staffeln, bevor man aufhhört so die Kurve kriegen und das dann irgendwie so auf einen Punkt hinzusteuern lassen. So haben die es ja gemacht, die haben ja gesagt. Die wussten ja auch schon, dass es endet, ne? Ja, die haben ja gesagt, wir machen noch zwei Staffeln mit 13 Folgen. Und dann haben sie das Ende überlegt und haben dann von da aus zurückgeschrieben. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass die ganzen Charaktere ja gar nicht mehr angelegt waren für diese ganzen, also es gab ja keinen abgeschlossenen Handlungsbogen, den man sich mal belegt hat und so.
Und die ganzen Charakterreisen waren ja schon mal abgeschlossen zu einem gewissen Punkt, noch auserzählt. Und dann ist ja genau das, was du gerade sagst. Wir sind gerade in einer Zeit, wo Leute einfach, natürlich auch weil Geld hintersteckt und Geld zu machen ist, das bekommen, was sie wollen. Und diese vor allem wirtschaftlich denkenden Konzerne ja dann sagen, okay, dann machen wir noch zehn Staffeln.
Und noch, gehen wir vor uns halt noch,
was war das jetzt dann, drei, vier Staffeln.
Und dann waren die Figuren darauf nicht mehr ausgelegt und eigentlich
auch teilweise auserzählt. Aber dann
ist der Charakter super beliebt und keine Ahnung,
wir wollen mehr Daenerys und keine Ahnung,
Jon Snow war dann plötzlich so eine popkulturelle
Figur. Und dann muss man
natürlich sich da was aus dem Hahn ziehen. Und dass es dann nicht allen gefällt, das ist ja dann irgendwie auch so ein bisschen klar. Ich finde es auch interessant, weil es auch so ein bisschen ich habe ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, wie sehr, glaube ich, dann auch vielleicht so ein Charakter, sondern es von der Serie, von der Rezeption geprägt ist, weil es irgendwie immer hieß, auf Game of Thrones ist die Serie mit den megakrassen Twists und wo ständig Leute sterben, ständig Protagonisten sterben. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, gerade in der letzten Staffel, dass die fast ausschließlich auf Twists und Tode geschrieben wurde. Also als würden die Drehbuchautoren drin sitzen, wir müssen jetzt auch ein bisschen an die Reaction-Videos denken. Wir müssen jetzt so ein bisschen überlegen, was ist der große, oh jetzt dreht sich nochmal alles Moment. Und so haben sie es tatsächlich oft auch im Making-off gesagt irgendwie so. Was sind so die grossen Momente, wo nochmal sich alles dreht? Und ich glaube schon, dass man da in den ersten Staffeln das vielleicht gar nicht so drauf geschrieben hat, sondern einfach diese Perflikte erzählt hat. Ja, das ist eine absurde Art. Also genau, und solche Momente profitieren davon, wenn die Figuren
davor eine organische, und
Josh Arnmaten ist halt so ein Typ,
der baut Figuren,
so ein Schachbrett mit Figuren auf,
und dann sind es wirklich tolle, vielschichtige
Charaktere, und die lässt er dann einfach mal
handeln, und lässt sie in seinem Kopf
dann aufeinandertreffen und überlegt,
okay, wenn diese Figuren aufeinandertreffen, was würde dann passieren,
und wie würden die damit umgehen, und hat halt so eine organische Reise erzählt. Und dann gibt es halt die anderen, das sind übrigens die Panzer, die nennt man so, die einfach dann mal drauf losschreiben. Stephen King ist auch so jemand. Und dann gibt es die Plotter, die genau wissen, wo ihre Reise endet, die eher von Plotpoints dann ausgehen und die quasi sich vorher, bevor sie überhaupt den ersten Satz eines Drehbuchs schreiben, sich schon darüber im Klaren sind, was die Charakterreisen so sind. Und das gibt auch, es ist nicht alles schwarz-weiss, manche machen auch so ein Mittelding und so, aber es ist doch George Arnormaten, dem war halt scheißegal, wo die Figuren endet, keine Ahnung gehabt und hat einfach mal losgeschrieben. Und wenn dann plötzlich Autoren, wahrscheinlich auch von HBO, also von den Studios, die Ansagen bekommen, nee, aber das Internet will, dass ihr Twists erzählt, dann platzt das natürlich aufeinander, diese beiden Arbeitsweisen. Und das Ausgangsmaterial und die neue Herangehensweise geht dann auch nicht gut zusammen dann. Es ist auch total schwierig, wie man mit dem eigenen Ruf seiner eigenen Serie umgeht, weil wenn du jetzt die ersten Staffeln und es kennt noch niemand, dann ist es berühmt und dann heißt es plötzlich, ah, Game of Thrones ist die Serie mit den Twists und jetzt schreibst du die nächste Staffel für deine Serie mit den Twists und das ist ja schon blöd, weil einerseits erwarten die Leute jetzt Twists, andererseits legt ein Twist davon, dass man ihn nicht erwartet und dann, glaube ich, kann man sich da schon sehr schnell verheddern irgendwie. Ist nicht auch ein Twist, wenn wir keinen Twist erzählen, ist doch gut. Weil man dann mit einer Erwartungshaltung arbeitet, die eigentlich gar nicht von einem selbst kommt, aber es ist schwierig. Naja, wir haben das Finale gesehen und jetzt ist es vorbei. Ich bin auch ganz froh, dass es vorbei ist. Ich war nicht so involviert in die letzte Staffel irgendwie. Ich war da emotional, hatte mich schon ins Rettungsboot geflüchtet und
naja. Man sagt ja eigentlich, dass man
die ersten Staffel
schreiben die Autoren, die zweite
Staffel schreiben die Autoren mit
den Schauspielern zusammen und
ab der dritten Staffel schreibt man
für die Schauspieler.
Das sagt man eigentlich so, weil
und das merkt man ja auch, wenn man sich mal
die Anzahl der Sex-Szenen anguckt bei Game of Thrones, merkt man das, finde ich, ganz gut. Einfach weil am Ende die Schauspieler zu teure Verträge haben und zu krass handeln und zu viel Macht haben auch. Ja, alle haben verhandelt, dass sie weniger Sexszenen hatten, ausser diese eine Nebenfigur, einer dieser Speerträger im Palast, der meinte, er will extra in seinen Vertrag reingeschrieben haben, dass er noch drei Sexszenen hat, also da wurde natürlich alles auf diese eine Figur fokussiert, oft im Hintergrund, aber den kriegst du halt auch nicht mehr raus, wenn der einmal den Speer gehalten hat. Ich will mehr Sex sehen. Ja, sind Statist. Ja, im Vertrag steht 30,16.
Ja gut, sie waren jetzt schon mal in der zweiten Staffel im Hintergrund zu sehen, da würden jetzt die Fans natürlich zerfleischen, wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr den Schild und den Speer tragen.
Ja, okay, gut, dann machen wir's.
Mit Daenerys. Ich hätte gerne eine Sexszene mit Daenerys Targaryen.
Okay, gut. Und ich will den Drachen reiten.
Ah, fuck. Scheiße, das wird teuer, die Postproben. Die übrigens in Köln gemacht werden, die Drachen, weiss ich nicht genau, habe ich mal gehört. Nee, wirklich? Ich dachte in Berlin. Ja, oder Berlin. Nie gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Auf jeden Fall in Deutschland werden die Drachen animiert, was ich sehr interessant fand. Wir haben für gute Arbeit ja auch mal einen Drachen gekauft und ich wusste gar nicht, dass man diese Modelle einfach kaufen kann und einfach dann benutzen kann.
Und lustigerweise kam es, hast du ja neulich im Nieu-Magazin vielleicht gesehen, gab es dann ein Game of Thrones-Einspieler mit einem Drachen.
Und das war der gute Arbeit Drache. Der wurde damals gekauft,
gepflegt, gefüttert
und war ein nicht teurer
Unterhalt, aber dann konnte man ihn wieder
ein bisschen gewachsen und konnte man ihn
nach ein paar Jahren wieder gebrauchen. Auch nicht schlecht.
Gute Investition. War eine gute Investition.
Die Mäuse
stehen halt noch so ein bisschen ungenutzt rum.
Da haben wir ein paar gekauft.
Das war ein Problem. Eine ganze Kiste voller animierter Mäuse und die will niemand so. Die waren auch teuer, weil ein Drache kostet so viel wie sechs Mäuse, aber die braucht man halt sehr selten für einen Spieler. Da muss man sich überlegen, was man kauft. Also, wenn ihr irgendwie Platz habt für animierte Mäuse, dann sagt uns Bescheid, schreibt eine Mail an zentrale-atmizofo.fail Das wäre echt super. Ah, es ist wieder sehr spät geworden heute, es ist wahnsinnig spät. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was mit uns los ist, aber wir nehmen immer so spät auf, weil keine Zeit. Ja, weil du keine Zeit hast vor allem. Das stimmt. Und dann kommst du ja noch vom EDM-Training und aber EDM heißt doch Electronic Dance Music, oder? Ja, ich komme auch nicht vom EDM-Training, ich komme vom EMS. Du hast aber EDM-Training geschrieben. EMS-Training habe ich geschrieben. Ach, EMS. Ach so, sorry. Elektromuskulaturstimulation, glaube ich. Das ist wieder auf der Suche nach neuer Musik und ich glaube, ich bin jetzt wirklich kurz davor aufzugeben, irgendwie, jede Musik nervt mich, ich weiß es nicht, irgendwie, muss jeder Mensch Musik mögen oder gibt es einfach auch Menschen, die sagen, ich kann damit nichts anfangen oder gibt es einfach für jeden Menschen die perfekte Musik? Ich weiß nicht, ich bin der falsche Ansprechpartner dafür, weil ich bin, ich reagiere hyper emotional auf Musik. Also ich bin wahnsinnig schnell super ergriffen oder abgeneigt. Und das ist auch ein großer Grund, warum ich abends nicht so gern ausgehe, weil ich super schnell auf Musik reagiere. Und wenn die Musik mir nicht gefällt, was in wirklich vielen Prozent der Fall ist, dann habe ich ganz schlechte Laune und werde auch dann ganz still und so, weil ich einfach so hyper emotional auf diese Musik reagiere. Das habe ich immer schon mal gemerkt. Und deswegen kann ich damit nicht so viel anfangen mit dem, was du sagst, weil ich dann sehr sehr viel Musik in meinem Leben brauche. Es ist interessant, du bist der einzige Mensch, den ich kenne, der negativ auf Musik reagiert. Nicht negativ ist es schon, dass ich Musik mag, aber irgendwie habe ich noch, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich habe noch nicht die gefunden, wo, also stell dir vor, du trägst immer Schuhe, die dir ein bisschen zu klein oder zu groß sind. Das Konzept Schuh funktioniert an sich schon okay, deine Füsse werden nicht nass. Aber du hast noch nicht so das Gefühl, dass es so richtig passt und dann überlegst du dir, sind Schuhe vielleicht immer ein bisschen falsch oder gibt es die richtigen Schuhe oder ich weiß es nicht. Es passt ja auch nicht alles immer. Es geht ja auch an deinem eigenen selber, dass man die Ansprüche einfach vielleicht nicht richtig tariert hat. Ich glaube, bei dir ist auch so ein bisschen, du denkst zu viel nach und du willst auch nicht, dass dir manche Musikrichtungen gefallen. Beispiel, immer wenn ich sage, ich höre manchmal gerne Rockmusik, verdrehst du immer die Augen. Ja, das hängt auch an der Allergie. Ja gut, weil du zum Strand sollst, weil du zurück ins Wasser sollst, du scheisse Einzeller. Nee, aber ich glaube, du musst dir manchmal einfach eingestehen, dass Heavy Metal deine Musikrichtung ist. Ich glaube, was mein Problem ist ein bisschen, ist wie in unserer Kultur Musik angeboten wird. Und damit meine ich vor allem das Konzept Album. Ich bin überhaupt kein Albenhörer, so dass man sagt, ich höre dieses Album. Sondern wenn dann einzelne Songs irgendwie zusammengefrickelt, ich bin eher dann Playlist, aber auch nicht so eine, ah, jetzt die Rock'n'Roll-Playlist, sondern verschiedene Genres.
Ich glaube, ich habe für mich noch nicht so die richtige Bündelmechanik gefunden, weil irgendwie man konsumiert es ja häufig so in Alben oder in Künstlern, aber beides funktioniert noch nicht so richtig.
Ich bräuchte eher wie so eine Art so ein Sud irgendwie, wo alles so in sich übereinander schwebt und dann nicht so, ha, jetzt ein Album, zwei Alben, sondern ich habe es auch noch nicht ganz verstanden. Es ist tatsächlich, es ist wirklich interessant, ihr müsst echt aufpassen bei Spotify, weil meiner Erfahrung nach sind alle unfassbar transparent und wenn man Namen, das erste, was ich mache, wenn ich Leute stal, ist, die bei Spotify einzugeben, weil man muss sagen, bei 90 Prozent der Fälle sind die Playlists öffentlich. Alles von euch ist öffentlich. Das ist nämlich sehr gut versteckt von Spotify, diese Playlisten geheim zu halten. Das ist nicht so einfach. Viele haben privates Hören, das heißt, man sieht nicht mehr zumindest, was ihr gerade hört oder was ihr in der letzten Zeit gehört habt, aber man sieht zumindest alle Playlists häufig und das ist echt lustig, weil alle haben da unterschiedliche Systeme und die einen haben Uppers, Downers und haben oft auch eine Sad-Playlist und eine Happy-Playlist und eine Weggeh-Playlist und eine Gut-Drauf-Werden-Playlist und ich glaube, ich habe schon viele Treffen abgesagt mit Blick auf die Playlist davor. Man kann sich vor vielen, vielen Fehlern bewahren. Und Spotify ist vor allem auch einfach sehr gut darin, deine Schwächen auszunutzen. Wenn du einmal irgendwie drei Uhr nachts so einen Schwachmoment hast und dann irgendwas anmachst, irgendwie dann noch Stacey Urico und dann die nächsten vierzehn Jahre, jedes Mal empfohlene Alben, Stacey Urico. Und ich hab zum Beispiel, und also ich glaube, Spotify denkt in so ganz merkwürdigen Kategorien teilweise auch, weil ich hab dann zum Beispiel einmal irgendwo ein afrikanisches Lied gehört, aus Afrika. Und ich hab ein Lied gehört und hab es dann zu meinen Favoriten hinzugefügt. Und seitdem krieg ich ständig afrikanische Künstler und Alben vorgestellt. Und das ist ja an sich nicht
schlecht, nur was mir an dem Lied
gefallen hat, ist ja jetzt nicht notwendigerweise
der Kontinent, in dem
es produziert wurde, sondern
vielleicht auch so...
Du kennst das doch von einem Beispiel Fahrradladen.
Wenn du dir da einmal
Interesse an diesem einen Fahrrad bekundest,
was bislang noch niemand kaufen wollte,
dann natürlich kommt der Typ noch ein paar Mal auf dich zu und fragt, ob du nicht doch das Fahrrad kaufen willst. Und du hast jetzt halt, afrikanische Musik ist wahrscheinlich nicht das beliebteste Genre auf Spotify. Und du hast jetzt einfach so Interesse bekundet und Spotify will jetzt einfach die Klicks, die wollen jetzt einfach die afrikanische Musik aus der letzten Ecke loswerden. Und dann irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, und dann war wirklich so, hier, Künstler aus Äthiopien, wo es dann wirklich einfach speziell wird. Und ich sage ja auch nicht, dass es schlecht ist, und manches davon gefällt mir auch, aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Spotify noch nicht genau gecheckt hat, wie Musik funktioniert und dass man nicht notwendigerweise, wenn man jetzt einen Künstler, der ein gelbes T-Shirt trägt, hört, dann irgendwie den Rest seines Lebens vorgeschlagen bekommen möchte, hier sind weitere Künstler mit gelben T-Shirts, vielleicht mal ein etwas helleres Gelb oder ein dunkleres Gelb und du hörst einfach Musik, die dich einfach innerlich auffrisst und du weißt einfach nicht wohin und du bist völlig verloren. Hey, hey, hey, afrikanische Musik frisst einen nicht notwendigerweise von innen auf. Nicht nur gut in 90% der Fans. Ich bin kein Musikkritiker, ich bin jetzt kein Musikkritiker, deswegen könnt ihr diese Aussage ein bisschen relativieren, aber ich glaube, führende Musikologen werden mir dazustimmen, ansonsten bin ich auch gern bereit, eure Meinung zu hören.
Solange der Reggaeton nicht vorgeschlagen wird, ist doch alles okay. Aber ich bin sehr zufrieden. Ich bin vor allem zufrieden mit der Discover Weekly-Liste und man kann auch mit gewissen Apps, zum Beispiel der coolen, super coolen App If This Then That, kannst du dir selber
einen Algorithmus erstellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob
Algorithmus der richtige Begriff dafür ist, weil es
eigentlich nur eine Wenn-Dann
Verkettung ist. Man kann
die auch einfach speichern und man kann
eine Playlist erstellen, weil man
ich komme oft nicht dazu, mir meine
Discover Weekly Sachen anzuhören
und deswegen werden die in eine grosse Playlist
gepackt, wo mittlerweile über tausend Songs
drin sind. Und das ist ganz geil.
Ja, aber bei mir ist irgendwie, ich habe das Gefühl,
meine Discover Weekly Playlist ist einfach
wie so ein betrunkener
Autofahrer, der immer so ganz
weit nach links lenkt und dann merkt,
holy shit, da kommt das Ende der Straße
dann ganz stark nach rechts lenkt.
Und ich habe immer dann so ganz viel afrikanische Musiker, da denke ich mir, gut, um dem so ein bisschen entgegenzuarbeiten, muss ich jetzt wieder ganz viel amerikanische Musik hören. Ich versuche so geografisch wieder zurück nach Europa zu kommen. Aber in der Metapher bist du gerade links gelenkt. Du bist aber gerade der Besucher, Autofahrer in der Metapher. Ich sage sag, Spotify ist das Auto und ich hab die Kontrolle übers Auto verloren. Und was ich bräuchte bei dem Discover Weekly, wäre einfach so ein Reset-Knopf, so ein Wir vergessen jetzt einfach mal alles, was passiert. Ich brauch ein neues Auto. Ich brauch einfach einen Neuanfang, wo man einfach sagt, wir vergessen jetzt mal alles, wir fangen bei null an, Punkt eins. Ja, und dann öffnest du, und dann löscht du dein Profil, startest an, und dann kommst du wieder auf irgendwann das äthiopische Lied. Oder weil es noch offen ist vielleicht. Startest du das zuerst. Nein! Nein, nicht schon wieder! Ja, das ist so diese Kotletten-Situation, wo man dann eine Kotlette hochrasiert, und dann muss die andere noch ein Stück höher, und irgendwann hat man sich komplett den Kopf rasiert. Und so ist mein Musikerleben auch gerade so, dass ich einfach wildes Lenkrad hin und her reiße und einfach, ich habe, ich bin verloren. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, also ihr habt eine lustige Antwort bekommen. Surfer interessieren sich nicht für Sand, sondern für Wellen. Der morgendliche Swell Report ist das Morgengebet. Es gibt bestimmt zig Wörter für Wellen, zumindest für Wellenreiter. Bei Wind- und Kitesurfer kommt noch Windfachbegriffe dazu. Okay. Ich lösche ihn jetzt. Generell, nur weil ein Tweet ein Fragezeichen beinhaltet, heißt es nicht notwendigerweise, dass man... Das ist so interessant! Doch, das macht so viel mit den Leuten. Ich behaupte, sobald ein Tweet ein Fragezeichen hat, es könnte die bescheuerte Frage sein, aber es haben Leute das Bedürfnis, eher zu antworten. Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Ja. Ach, ich lasse ihn jetzt. Das ist mir ja unangenehm. Innerhalb dieser Podcast-Folge hat dieser Tweet gelebt und er ist gescheitert und er wird für immer und ewig gespeichert sein. Ja, ist schon okay. Hast du noch einen Musik-Tipp für unsere Hörer? Für alle, die so ein bisschen verloren sind und nicht wissen, wohin? Ich habe einen ganz speziellen Musikgeschmack. Ich finde, äh, nee, eigentlich nicht. Ich habe kurz gedacht, ich haue einen raus. Ich höre eigentlich nur alte Musik. Ich bin ein großer Fan von, das ist mir alles unangenehm. Ich weiß nicht, warum mir Musikkrieg so unangenehm ist. Me and Julio Down by the Schoolyard von Paul Simon möchte ich gerne empfehlen. Das ist ein richtiger Insider-Tipp, Leute. Hör ich gleich rein, lass mir den Bart ein und hör rein. Und ich wünsche euch allen ganz viel Spaß. Und was soll ich sagen, nächste Woche beginnt deine Serie. Ich bin nur aufgeregt, weil nächste Woche ist die Premiere, die Deutschlandpremiere und dann auch der Start. 31. Mai. Und das war echt weird, weil ich habe heute eine Mail bekommen, diese Netflix-Mail, die man immer bekommt, wenn neue Serien starten, von der Serie, die ich mitgeschrieben habe und das war sehr verwirrend Danach habe ich erfahren, dass diese Mail an 40 Millionen Leute ging.
40 Millionen Leute.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, krass, ich habe mit nichts,
an dem ich jemals mitgearbeitet habe, so viele Leute erreicht.
Und dann habe ich mich sehr gefreut.
Wie lange hat das jetzt gedauert, also von
dem allerersten Mal, wo du damit in Berührung gekommen bist,
bis jetzt? Anderthalb Jahre.
Anderthalb Jahre? Bis jetzt zwei Jahre.
Zwei Jahre.
Wird alles in einer Woche seinen Abschluss finden,
am 31. Mai, wenn ihr auf Netflix
Das ist alles sehr aufregend, können wir ja nächste Woche darüber sprechen, denn dann ist ja erst die Release-Woche. Vielen Dank, Florentin, für dieses schöne Gespräch, für dieses tolle Telefonat.
Ja, mach's gut und an euch auch viel Spaß und ... Danke an Lars fürs Intro.